hey wisecrack this is Jared clown Prince
of wisecrack and today we're talking
about the guy people have in mind when
they say that Batman has all the best
villains everyone's favorite nihilists
the Joker I have nothing to live for
making his first appearance in 1940's
Batman number one the world's busiest
evil clown has been featured in hundreds
of comics and cartoons dozens of video
games and four live-action films and now
you'll watch inspired by Victor Hugo's
hero gwyn plane in the 1928 film
adaptation of the man who laughs the
Joker's motives have ranged from the
sadistic what hurts more to the
mercenary I would be rich forever to the
downright inexplicable confusing isn't
it but despite the fact that hundreds of
creative minds have worked on the Joker
is outlook on the world has been
surprisingly consistent and it
represents an extreme version of a
reaction we've all felt towards the
world at one point or another so put a
smile on that face and enjoy this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
the Joker part one one bad day there are
a lot of explanations for just how the
Joker got to be the Joker you know how I
got these scars the first account of the
Joker's origin was revealed in Detective
Comics number 168 back in 1951 and over
the past six decades most versions have
followed more or less the same plotline
a two-bit villain known as the Red Hood
loses a fight to Batman falls into a vat
of skin bleaching and hair brightening
chemicals and emerges as something
entirely new
over time DC built on this origin story
Alan Moore's 1986 magnum opus The
Killing Joke made the Joker's origin a
lot more tragic making him a reluctant
villain who lost his humanity after one
bad day where he failed as a stand-up
comic nobody laughs was informed of the
death of his pregnant wife there was an
accident this morning got framed by the
mob and only then fell into a vat of
disfiguring chemicals oh the entire
premise of The Killing Joke was that the
Joker hoped to turn Commissioner Gordon
into another version of himself by
giving Gordon a similarly bad day to
prove that even the best of us are never
more than one bad day away from becoming
well whatever the Joker is more on that
later while The Killing Joke is
technically
not a canonical story and the Joker
gives a strong indication that he has no
idea whether this version of his history
is accurate anyway sometimes I remember
it one way the Comics animated series
and games have mostly stuck by Alan
Moore's depressing version of the
Joker's origins ever since really I must
be falling into a rut Batman and the
Joker have something in common
both live their lives as responses to
traumatic worldview shattering events
events that represent an existential
crisis that most people have to deal
with sooner or later how do you respond
when life destroys your sense of meaning
Batman reacts to his parents death by
dressing up in a bat your leotard and
battering criminals which seems
reasonable enough by comic book
standards but the Joker's one bad day
led him with equal passion to embrace
meaninglessness and violence after all
if moral nihilism is correct then
nothing is right or wrong
according to French existentialist
philosopher jean-paul Sartre recognising
the meaninglessness of existence sources
us to realize that we are responsible
for creating our own meaning choosing
how to deal with this loss of meaning
animates the entire Batman universe
Batman decides to uphold some form of
conventional morality as a vigilante The
Joker chooses to abandon it entirely and
the villain two-face splits the
difference literally flipping a coin to
decide whether he'll uphold conventional
morality or rebel against it although
the Batman persona is usually presented
as a response to personal trauma not
nihilism more recent versions of the
character have begun to sound more and
more existential I bet your parents
taught you
means something you're here for a reason
my parents taught me a different lesson
dying in the gutter no reason at all
they taught me in the world only I sense
if you force it to the Joker is aware of
this distinction between himself in the
dark night and in recent iterations of
the character he even feels a kinship
with him you complete me
this places Batman in the Joker in an
existential struggle this is what
happens when an unstoppable force meets
an immovable object
Batman is trying to convince the Joker
to accept conventional morality while
the Joker is trying to seduce Batman
into abandoning it 1989's Batman
connected the characters even more
directly making the two-bit mobster Jack
Napier the original killer of Batman's
parents and it was Batman who later sent
Napier tumbling into the chemical that
turning him into the Joker they gave
birth to each other I was a kid I killed
your parents I mean I say I made you you
gotta say you made me how childish yeah
in Nolan's The Dark Knight Batman and
the Joker are already fully formed by
the time they meet Heath Ledger's Joker
was different from any version that
preceded him different from any other
villain in cinema really as an elemental
force of chaos with supernatural
charisma planning and dumb luck he
didn't have or need a consistent origin
story life I had a wife he was more of a
demon summoned by Batman's enemies to
fight him own a no other alias gothic in
his pockets but knives and lint a demon
they soon learned that they couldn't
control you cross the line for so you
squeezed him you hammered him to the
point of desperation and in their
desperation they turned to a man they
didn't fully own
stand in other words in the world of the
Dark Knight The Joker's presence in
Gotham City is entirely Batman's fault I
like tonight
what are you superstitious you got more
chance of winning the Powerball than
running into him by introducing
oppressive justice and order he has
thrown the moral universe of Gotham out
of balance and created opportunity for a
new kind of chaos and evil to emerge aha
I thought my jokes were bad this idea of
society without balance is central to
the philosophy of French sociologist
Jean Baudrillard in the transparency of
evil he argues that the kind of moral
progress Batman seeks would be
impossible because even as he seeks to
uphold justice by making criminals his
[ __ ]
he creates more extreme versions of
order for criminals to challenge and
subvert well hire the clown it was right
laughs the figs are you that's them thus
giving birth to a radically antithetical
version of Batman's brand of justice the
Joker in trying to completely sanitized
Gotham of evil Batman
essentially created a super germ a kind
of autoimmunity disease in the form of
the Joker in Baudrillard words all
liberation effects good and evil equally
the liberation of morals and minds
entails crimes and catastrophes the
liberation of law and pleasure leads
inevitably to the liberation of crime
according to baudrillard evil isn't the
opposite of good if something unpleasant
happens to you that doesn't mean it's
evil evil is characterized by a radical
indifference to good this is essentially
the Joker instead of merely making bad
things happen to people like other
supervillains the Joker has a more
sinister goal to completely destroy the
concept of what good even means each of
you has
blow up the other bone nobody ever
labels themselves as evil everyone
considers themself to be good so the
Joker tries to seduce Batman Gordon and
others into abandoning their moral
foundations and do something they'd
never see themselves doing thereby
corrupting their understanding of
goodness he is mischievous passion for
breaking down people's confidence in the
division between good and evil is
exactly what makes the Joker so
intriguing most other villains combat
good with the opposite the Joker
destroys good in the end
Batman wins the fight but the Joker wins
the argument the once idealistic Harvey
Dent is now completely indifferent to
the distinction between good and evil
the only morality the cruel world is
chance unbiased unprejudiced whether
he's trying to leave his deadly imprint
on the world around him or just break
down one character's moral compass I
just wanted to bring down your grim
facade and for once let you see the
world as I see it giggling in a corner
and bleeding The Joker's objective seems
to be to show us that our pretenses to
love and morality are phony and that
were a lot more self-serving than we let
on to prove a point but I suppose the
question still remains why does he
bother it's a cop-out to say the Joker
is mentally ill the common
classification of the Joker as insane
seems to just be a way of demonstrating
how little we understand about how his
mind works and why it takes a similarly
dark and eccentric character to figure
him out what makes the Joker violent in
other words isn't a psychiatric problem
it's an existential one he is
pathologically sane and he's seen how
fragile conventional morality is see
their morals their code
it's a bad joke he believes that no one
is more than one sufficiently bad day
away from total depravity but the Joker
doesn't just abandon traditional moral
codes he subverts them with a sinister
kind of humor part two why so serious
the Joker is a joker just like it says
on the tin he resembles a clown he has a
huge permanent grin and he's been known
to use elaborate slapstick based murder
weapons it's his gimmick and for most of
the characters history it's been just a
gimmick but starting with the
publication of The Killing Joke in 1988
and continuing through the release of
The Dark Knight in 2008 there's been a
darker undertone to it he enjoys doing
wretched horrifying stuff it's funny to
him The Joker jokes because from his
point of view everything is trivial and
while it's easy to write him off as a
sadist his regular attempts to tempt
people into doing things that upset
their own sense of right and wrong and
reveal their hypocrisy may speak to the
very heart of what humor is in book 1 of
his masterpiece the world as will and
representation German philosopher and
prodigy firestarter hair model Arthur
Schopenhauer wrote that the cause of
laughter in every case is simply the
sudden perception of an incongruity
between a concept and the real object
laughter itself is just the expression
of this incongruity all laughter is then
occasioned by a paradox this briefly
sated is the true explanation of the
ludicrous the idea of finding humor and
nihilism isn't really new and in smaller
doses it can be a great survival
mechanism in laughing at nothing humor
as a response to nihilism the
contemporary American philosopher John
Maher mish argues that laughing at the
void can be a really healthy thing to do
my heart wasn't in it so I quit to be a
comedian to make people laugh because
when they laugh they feel good
the nihilist in claiming that our fate
is unfair unwanted and unfavorable need
not collapse into despair rather with
humor this individual might understand
life as part of a cosmic drama that is
amusing in its ultimate absurdity
because the Joker is an active and even
joyfully fanatical nihilist who sees it
as his duty to confront imposed moral
order with the reality of chaos isn't
your life revolves around identifying
incongruities between what we say we are
moral righteous good citizens and what
we actually are selfish savage creatures
they got me early on my mother's
hospital bills don't and he's having a
great time doing it according to the
Joker conventional morality and the
social structures built around those
ideas are flimsy and weak he believes
that nobody is ever more than one bad
day away from abandoning it his entire
career as a villain centers on giving
people that one bad day he thinks they
need to end up just like him
madness as you know is like gravity all
it takes is a little push The Joker's
signature weapon Joker venom is a deadly
gas that kills its victims by forcing
them to laugh themselves to death while
their face contorts into a rictus grin
just like his own he'll be alright and
Joker venom is as old as the character
he used it in his debut appearance in
1940's Batman number one and most
versions of the Joker used some version
of it smile I could agree oh yeah
yeah proving everyone's capable of
becoming what he is both morally and
physically it's the Joker's greatest
pleasure and obsession I give you the
average bat and it has made the
character terrifying and relevant for
most of the past century it's his
killing joke conclusion it's hard to
resist the temptation to glamorize the
Joker a little bit partly because he's
been around so long that we developed a
certain amount of affection for the guy
life's been good to me and when you look
at the scale of human suffering
injustice hypocrisy and greed it's easy
to relate to the Joker's commitment to
proving we're not as noble as we pretend
to be but he isn't heroic either and he
isn't supposed to be there have been
some stories where the Joker did
seemingly heroic things that were
consistent with his character in the
1996 Marvel DC crossover Batman in
Captain America he turned against Red
Skull and refused to join the Third
Reich and in the 2006 conclusion of DC's
Infinite Crisis he brutally executed the
near omnipotent Lex Luthor for being too
much of a control freak but in both
cases writers cleverly avoided having
him turn over a new leaf giving him
plausible selfish motives that justified
his uncharacteristic helpfulness no
please don't insult me but the Joker
wouldn't make a very effective villain
if we didn't all have a little bit of
him in us we're suspicious of other
people's moral codes reliable to fixate
on their hypocrisy at the expense of our
own and we all have moments where we
just kind of want to watch the world
burn he's still smiling at us and we're
still smiling back hey everyone thanks
for watching hope you guys enjoyed it we
had a great time working on it the Joker
is one of my absolute favorite
characters and this was a video I was
dying to make now just a few things
click here to visit our channel page
where you can find another Batman video
to watch and subscribe we have some big
episodes around the corner and
subscribing as the way to get notified
when they drop also I want to tell you
about a great Channel you should know
about called comic book resources these
guys are just getting started but
they're already making awesome videos
diving into comic book lore geeky
backstories character breakdowns and
more click here to visit their channel
page and subscribe and check out their
video on the Joker it tries to determine
which is the best Joker of them all
leave a comment and tell my scrag sent
you and finally take a quick minute to
visit our patreon page here if you
become a patron before August 13th
you'll get an exclusive and live
behind-the-scenes tour of our earthling
cinema set so be sure to check it out
alright enough for me I literally have
to go run to a friend's wedding so catch
you guys next time wisecrack peace